Lightyear is a very large distance like
the light a light year is the distance
that light travels in a year and light
travels at the blindingly fast speed
300,000 kilometers every second so if
you think about that for an entire year
that light's gone a very long way so all
your light years a very large unit for
some reason astronomers really don't
like using light years I've never it's
like it's slightly a snobbish thing but
you know that they're kind of they're in
science fiction and therefore you know
real scientists don't use them and so
astronomers instead tend to use this
instead tend to use this unit called the
parsec which is actually it's sort of
comparable in size to it to a Lightyear
a parsec is about three light-years so
it's a bit bigger than a Lightyear
parsec is actually it's an abbreviation
it's short for a parallax arcsecond and
what I still with the second part of
that first an arcsecond
is a unit of angle so if you divide a
circle up into 360 degrees and then each
of those degrees is divided into 60 arc
minutes and then each of those our
minutes is divided into 60 arc seconds
so an arc second is one 3600 of a degree
which is then one three hundred and
sixtieth of a circle which just
basically means is a very very small
angle so as an arc second so that's the
the angle side of it the arc second side
of it now the parallax side of it
parallax is it's used all the time in
fact you use it every day whenever
you're estimating the distance to
something relatively nearby and it's a
sort of the most direct way of
experiencing parallax is something that
suspect everyone is sort of familiar
with which is if you hold your finger up
in front of your nose and then you shot
one eye and then you shut the other eye
your finger appears to jump relative to
other things in the background which is
just basically because your eyes are
looking at your finger from slightly
different directions and so you see a
slightly different background behind it
depending on which eye you're looking
through and that effect the thing moving
is the is the the effect of parallax in
fact the word parallax is Greek it means
change it basically means that you're
changing your perspective and so you see
things see things move and of course you
use that in everyday life in order to
estimate the distances to things your
eyes all the time are looking for things
from slightly different directions
so that's parallax in everyday life you
can play exactly the same game in
astronomy you can measure the parallax
of things you can actually see if the
astronomical object is relatively nearby
it moves relative to the things in the
background just because you if you view
it from
two slightly different directions now in
that case it's no good using your eyes
because they're just too close together
and so actually because the distances
involved is so enormous the parallax's
are tiny and so what you need is to
observe an astronomical object from two
points which are a long way apart now
one way of doing that is to have two
observatories on earth that are kind of
separated by a live distance but in fact
in astronomy we can do even better than
that which is that all you have to do is
take a picture and then wait for six
months and of course the earth goes
around the Sun and then take another
picture and then you've actually moved
your baseline the direction from which
you're looking at by a large amount by
twice the distance between the Earth and
the Sun and so by making those kind of
measurements you can actually see nearby
stars for example move around that the
relatively nearby star when you view it
make one observation of it and then wait
six months and make another observation
if the star is moved and in fact if you
make a whole series of observations the
star just kind of wobbles backwards and
forwards and obviously the further away
the star is the less and less it wobbles
even the closest stars wobble back
really truly tiny amount this amount of
water an arcsecond
so the parallax of the closest stars is
about an arcsecond or thereabouts so
putting all this back together again the
definition of a parsec that this
parallax arcsecond it's the distance to
an object where it wobbles backwards and
forwards by one arcsecond over the
course of a year and as I say the
closest stars that parallax is about an
arc second so the closest by stars which
are about one parsec away that means
they wobble backwards and forwards over
the course of a year by about one arc
second or thereabouts so that's the
definition of a project to put this in
perspective it really is a very tiny
angle an arc second is something like
the width of a human hair viewed from
maybe 20 meters away so that's kind of
how small an arc second it's so that's
how little these stars warbling
backwards and forwards but it says
something about the precision with which
we can make astronomical measurements
now that we can easily measure those
kind of parallax's the largest parallax
is that we measure are around an arc
second so which means that the closest
objects are around a parsec and they're
things like nearby stars so the nearby
stars in the Milky Way around a parsec
away if you want to measure scales
within the Milky Way so where you know
how far it is to the other side of the
galaxy or how far it is to the center of
our galaxy then you're talking about
thousands of parsecs we usually call
that a killer parsec and so for example
the distance to
center of our galaxy is somewhere around
8,000 parsecs or eight kiloparsecs away
so if you want to measure distances
within the the Milky Way you usually use
kiloparsecs if you want to measure
distances to other galaxies then
typically there are millions of parsecs
away so nearby galaxies are maybe at
some decent fraction of a mega parsec
the the Andromeda galaxy for example our
nearest neighbor is some large fraction
of a mega parsec away the nearest
cluster of galaxies are the nearest
Vince collection of galaxies the Virgo
cluster is about 15 mega parsecs away
and then finally if you want to measure
things on kind of the scale of the
observable universe the most distant
measures that we can get there you're
talking about distances of around a
billion parsecs so again we typically
use a Giga parsec rather than putting
all those zeroes in